هذه الانقسامات الطوليه والافقيه انقسام
عسكري مع السياسيين انقسام الشارع مع
السياسيين انقسام السياسيين في بعضهم
مطالبات علنيه
بانسحاب جانس وبالتالي اسقاط الحكومه الى
اين يتجه المشهد في الداخل الاسرائيلي
رويدا
رويدا يعني عبد القادر ما وصفته هو بالضبط
مشهد غير مسبوق في اسرائيل هذه الفوضى
وهذا الارباك وعدم الثقه بين المؤسسات
المختلفه في اسرائيل وبين المجتمع وبين
الحكومه يعني يعني اذكرك انه بال 73 عندما
كان الاخفاق في حرب اكتوبر 73 لم لم يطالب
المجتمع الاسرائيلي باستقاله جولد مائير
الا بعد انتهاء الحرب في هذه الازمه هنالك
الان مطالبه باستقاله نتنياهو
بالاطاحة في داخل اسرائيل هذه الازمه
النابعه من عدم الثقه بالحكومه
الاسرائيليه بعدم الثقه بقدره هذه الحكومه
على تحقيق الاهداف العسكريه على استعاده
الاسرى والرهائن من قطاع غزه وايضا من عدم
الثقه ان الحرب باتت يعني من اجل استعاده
الردع الاسرائيلي وانما تحولت الى حرب من
اجل بقاء نتنياهو السياسي من اجل تنفيذ
الاجندات الايديولوجيه لليمين الاسرائيلي
ومن اجل وهذا الاهم التنصل من الاخفاق
الذي كان في السابع من اكتوبر هنالك في
محاوله من نتنياهو ومن اليمين الاسرائيلي
التنصل من المسؤوليه عن الاخفاق في السابع
من اكتوبر ولذلك هم يعني تصرفون بهذا
الشكل يريدون اخذ الحرب الى مكان اخر وكل
محاوله للمسائله حول السبع من اكتوبر يتم
التهجم على الجيش او على الجهه التي تسال
عن ذلك ولذلك هنالك في عدم ثقه ايضا
بنتنياهو كشخص وايضا بالحكومه الاسرائيليه
ك ك قادره على لاداره هذه الحرب ولذلك
عندما خرج بالامس جانس في خطابه وفي بيانه
للجمهور الاسرائيلي انا قلت ان هذه الخطوه
الاولى لخروج جانس من الحكومه هنالك الان
في ضغط شعبي عليه كبير جدا من اجل الخروج
من الحكومه لانه لم تعد هذه الحكومه حكومه
طوارئ لاداره الحرب انما تحولت الى حكومه
بقاء سياسي لنتنياهو ولليمين الاسرائيلي
ولذلك هنالك ما يسود المجتمع الاسرائيلي
الان المسجد الاسرائيلي هو غياب الثقه
دكتور م اريد ان افهم منك لماذا يعتبر
مؤشر ان يقوم 169 من قاده الجيش السابقين
بالتعبير عن دعمهم لرئيس الاركان عما جراه
في الاجتماع يوم الخميس حيال بعض الوزراء
لماذا يعتبر هذا مؤشر لافت ومهم في فهم ما
يجري في الداخل
الاسرائيلي اولا لانه رئيس هي الاركان هت
سليب تعرض الى هجوم من وزراء لم يخدموا في
الجيش في حياتهم يعني بنفير وسموت هم
شخصيتان يمنيت متطرف لم يخدموا ابدا في
الجيش الاسرائيلي ولذلك هم يهاجمون رئيس
هيئه الاركان على عمليات العسكريه في غزه
على ايه قراره بتشكيل فريق بحث في الاخفاق
في السب اكتوبر ولذلك خرج هؤلاء العسكريين
السابقين من اجل دعم الجيش الاسرائيلي
امام هذه الحكومه هذا يعني ان هنالك في
انقسام واضح بين المؤسسه العسكريه وما
تمثله وبين هذه الحكومه اليمينيه في في
داخل اسرائيل ولذلك خروج هؤلاء الجنرالات
والضباط السابقين لدعم الجيش هو عمليا نزع
الثقه والشرعيه عن قدره هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على اداره الحرب لانه
بالنهايه من الناحيه القانونيه والدستوريه
في اسرائيل الجيش الاسرائيلي هو تابع
للسلطه التنفيذيه بمعنى انه تابع للحكومه
وخروج هؤلاء الجنرالات السابقين ضد
الحكومه هذا معناه انهم ينزعون الشرعيه عن
هذه الحكومه في قدرتها على اداره الحرب
وعلى اداره الشؤون عسكريه ولذلك خروجهم
دعما للجيش الاسرائيلي ودعما لرئيس هيئه
الاركان هيرسي هاليفي هي ايضا تحمل رساله
سياسيه وليس فقط رساله عسكريه تحمل رساله
سياسيه ان هذه الحكومه لم تعد قادره على
اداره الحرب وهي غير مؤهله ويجب تغييرها
ايضا هناك نقطه تحتاج الى ربما الى توضيح
قبل ايام كانت فقط من خلال تسريبات
اعلاميه ولكنها الان تقال وكانه بشكل شبه
رسمي وصريح هذه التساؤلات لدى الجيش عن
الاجابه من قبل رئيس الوزراء عن اليوم
الذي يلي الحرب او الاهداف الحقيقيه لهذه
الحرب لماذا يعجز نتنياهو عن الاجابه على
هذا السؤال وبالتالي لا يجد الجيش اجابه
على هذا السؤال هل لك ان تشرح
لنا طبعا اولا نتنياهو لا يريد الاجاب عن
هذا السؤال لانه موجود في معدله سياسيه من
جهه اليمين الاسرائيلي يريد منه الاستمرار
في الحرب يريد تهجير اهل قطاع غزه يريد
الاستان في غزه اذا قال لهم لا فانهم سوف
يسقطو بمعنى انه اصبح رهي بنفسه واصبح
رهينا لليمين الاسرائيلي ولذلك هو افضل حل
بالنسبه له هو اطاله هذه الحرب واسكات
اليمين الاسرائيلي وتهديدات اليمين ضده
ومن جهه ثانيه لديه جانس وجلن الذين
يضغطون نحو وضع تصور اسرائيلي ل لغزه
ولذلك نتنياهو موجود بين قطبين في الحكومه
بين قطب يميني يريد استمرار في الحرب
والاستيطان في غزه وتهجير الفلسطينيين
وبين قطب اخر يريد وضع تصور سياسي قريب و
متماهية المسؤوليه لانه اولا من الناحيه
الدستوريه هو هو مسؤول عن الجيش ولذلك اي
اخفاق عسكري يجب ان يتحمل هو المسؤوليه
السياسيه الامر الثالث ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بسبب اخفاقه العسكري في قطاع
غزه اصبح يبحث عن خروج من هذا المازق افضل
افضل حل للخروج من المازق هو وضع هدف
سياسي هدف سياسي واقعي يستطيع ان يخرجه من
مازق العسكري